hello and welcome to the new world
review where we are all
ants all of us you're an ad and you're
an ant
and you get to eat some delicious human
flesh
we're all ants because ants have the
better society am i right
let's get into these episodes because
i'm a rambly theory monik and i will not
be stopped
give me my crown thank you episode 80.
coming back to this a decade i mean
a week later where were we oh that's
right we had the leader of the ngl
the king as it were also apparently the
guy who led the charge of selling drugs
to people outside of danger nature
heaven we had him captured and taken to
the queen ant and after the intro we
were thrown into this flashback sequence
that was somewhat interesting but
i had no understanding about why it
might be important until
the end or at least i didn't really
think it through a lot happened this
episode but we're gonna start with that
flashback sequence because it's probably
the darkest concept to grapple with and
we'll
work backward forward the first thing we
get to experience is a traumatized
person
getting broken into small pieces having
asked you last episode how you describe
darkness it was interesting that some of
you said that the concept of taboo is
what makes something dark or subverting
expectation or
evil winning because watching that
flashback the only taboo i saw was
actually
making clear that abuse does happen and
that the resulting experience scars the
person for the rest of their life we
have yet to see a subversion of
expectation to my mind but i'm sure
it'll come soon having a giant bug
eat kids came close anyway we learned
that a child could kill
adults we learned that he could get
angry enough to do to the universe what
it did to him
which is being uncaring but he also
decided to take it a few steps further
and not just be passively uncaring but
actively uncaring and i think the trope
of the traumatized insert person type
description here
is a really harmful one i've personally
come across a great deal of people
who have dealt with and are still
dealing with horrific trauma every day
are they raging against the world and
deliberately harming others to teach a
lesson
no they seek psychological help because
it's in their own and the world's best
interest
what happened to gyro was horrific and
it's interesting and probably important
that we never get any detail about him
except his eyes and his bald head so i
assume
he's the guy in the opening titles with
the bowler hat and the reason we see the
eyes at the end of them
it's also hugely important to know his
backstory unlike the previous episodes
in earlier arcs where we interacted with
the histories of characters and they
were
interesting yes but not important in
terms of storytelling method
it's a really clear indication that
togashi is actually improving as a
narrative craftsman
every piece of information given can
serve more than one purpose and we
really get that here we were given a
focused body part we were given the
character's motivation we were given an
indication of size and shape and
movement and
mental state we were shown the
proclivity to violence to solve problems
from a psychological standpoint that's
fascinating not unexpected but
fascinating
the fact that he killed rather than
running away there was nothing truly
binding him to that place at any time in
fact his dad actively didn't care and
that was his problem
how is he going to react to a queen who
actively does
care about him does he have the capacity
to care for someone who does care for
him he did when he thought his dad might
and yes he broke
as a result of not having that and the
person who looked after him
i want to know what happened to them the
person that actually did look after him
when he was ill
they tried an indication that someone in
the world did care about him
his focus was on his dad though and his
treatment of his dad as the center of
his universe correction
actually his treatment of his dad as the
universe right because the universe
doesn't give a damn about him
don't make trouble for humans he knew
then that he must not be human
and now he gets to not be human i do
wonder whether he'll be a just and good
king to the bugs because he knows what
it is to be different and ignored
and he knows how bad humans can be i
wonder whether he'll find a sense of
belonging
which is i think a big theme of this
particular art in a strange sort of
twisted and dark way so yeah we have
gyro coming back into being as the king
of the bugs i guess
maybe probably if not i'm gonna be
really angry he and pocastic giving over
his aura ponzi dead and eaton
knowing already how takashi treats women
in his story
i'm unsurprised that he went to the
extreme of having the crazy bug play
with a gun at her dead body it just
placed so hard into the madman with a
gun trope
what we do know is that she may have
saved them all so we also get the martyr
woman trope as well
goody the comedy of the spider-man bug
thing followed by the undressed scorpion
thing reinforced all those tropes so
miss me with that
let's move on episode 81 most
likely the damage here was done by a
chimera
ant no [ __ ] sherlock are you telling me
the reason we came here might be the
cause of this carnage that the six or
seven foot
ant whose nail we have might possibly
have been the reason for all of this
awfulness
you don't say now for a superhero run
i love this run what is it about this
run that's so typical superhero it's
like
i'm a superhero so i run like this i
love that run it's my favorite thing
that happens in anime that's
all yeah so they know now that the
chimera ants have control of the center
of the ngl and an idea popped into my
head that makes me
somewhat uncomfortable despite knowing
that it's not likely where we're going
or maybe we are i have no idea actually
it occurs to me that human behaviors and
traits turn up and dominate these
characters and creatures
and their behavior becomes very
human-centric we have such a desire for
revenge from our bunny bird boy ramot
birds sometimes show that desire to
protect their food but the revenge part
that
is strongly human what if the humans of
this world are actually all
chimera ants oh the difference is that
this ant queen looks like an ant because
that was the primary food of the queen
she came from
and if that were the case it would
explain why nen is rare
not all queens can get enough of it to
eat but it would also explain why the
other ants can see it because we've been
in situations to now where common humans
can't see that aura but then a few
episodes ago in kite's flashback jing
noted that
animals like hunters is it because they
want to eat them and consume the
nutritious
okay so maybe i'm wrong on that and i i
i don't know how i feel about that but
what if animals are all ants from
different colonies
is this a world of ants it would explain
why we haven't heard tale of a giant
chimera ant despite the fact that they
know what the ants are
and how they procreate and enough to
form a defensive perimeter in areas
they're known to exist
the diversity of creature is because the
queen has the genetics of several
animals but it seems like the human
personality of the thing she consumes is
the strongest so
it's a fascinating look at the concept
of reincarnation too
oh and the idea that civilizations grow
thrive and
and fall apart very quickly in sort of
the global scheme of things
and then there's diversity of thought
and the individual ideas coming up of
he who wants to do the best he can but
is maybe too sensitive a general
the fact that i expected colt to kill
remote in that moment says a lot about
me i guess
i expected colt to revert to sort of
basic human behavior and protect his
queen at all costs
that cost in this case being that ramot
was taking food from her and he's not
listening
in order to exert dominance that you
know i expected him to do something
about that she needs them to provide
food if they eat it then what and i
truly think
i truly did think it would be that step
for him but it hasn't happened yet
and that's a level of humanity that i
don't know that i ascribed until now to
this character
it might happen in the future then again
i'd also predict that colt is going to
end up killing the king because his
original mother is in harm's way or
something
it seems like this sort of thing that
would happen before he steps into a
portal and says
this world is too dangerous do not try
to follow
then gone and kill our follow because
they find out they too are bugs and
can't really live anywhere else i mean
this is my idea even copyright there are
so many ideas linked into this show at
the moment and so many different themes
and if i were to pull them all apart my
brain would feast on them heavily but
this is a review so i should probably be
reviewing the sound design for this
episode was standout specifically that
cracking noise that happened when remote
cracked and got angry
oh it made me feel things i don't even
have a word to describe the feeling that
i felt but it made me uncomfortable
and more emotions than that and speaking
of revenge
killing an important moment there was a
point in this episode when kite told
them they needed to be able to deal with
the chimera ants that i realize
i expect gone to kill in this arc and
the weird thing is that i expect gon to
kill
and i expect kite to be eaten and i
expect gone to be forced to kill him or
some such
there's a sort of tragic beauty to a
setup where we understand this growing
civilization where even though he's
angry with ramot
colt doesn't kill him or harm him but
tries to understand him instead
and then instead of trying to hold on to
the defiant troops tries to pull them
into a fold with a task that is just for
them
now that they all know about the hunters
gone kilauea and kite
are going to walk in like meals
declaring their arrival
it's going to be quite exciting to see
them try to get out without killing
everyone
or anyone because that's the point right
despite wanting to be stronger we
haven't as far as i can recall
had gone kill anyone kill sure that
kid's an assassin and doesn't pretend
he's not
gone though he's tried not to kill at
every turn here's an
enemy though who not only wants him dead
because he's dangerous but wants to eat
him to make their cause more powerful
and on top of that
narratively they've been humanized not
just in the fact that they have human
dna
but in the fact that we know their names
we know their habits we know their
personality and their social structure
it's an interesting predicament
takashi's setting up in this arc because
there is more depth in these characters
when they arrive
than there arguably is in any characters
that are not gone quilo
leorio or that other guy we haven't seen
in a while could uppercut that's the one
and even leorio doesn't have this level
of character development he's just been
around a fair bit
regardless of where the story goes
kite's warning to the boys was a warning
to us as an audience too
the focus on eyes in this arc is really
clear with that warning
no matter what happens next win or lose
they're going to hell
and we get to choose whether or not we
are going to go with them
so will they make it out and will they
make it out in one piece i have no idea
and i want to find out so join me next
episode to do that because for now
that's it from me if you enjoyed my
rambling hypotheses and thematic
querying click here here or somewhere
else i don't know for more don't forget
to hit like and subscribe
have a restful week and i'll see you
next time